[Music]
hey everyone welcome to another
installment of harry potter theory in
today's video we're going to once again
be covering the newly released second
secrets of dumbledore trailer which has
given us harry potter fans a lot to talk
about i mentioned a few of these
theories in my trailer breakdown video
link in description but i only scratched
the surface of them in that video and
not all of them so today i'm going to be
discussing in more depth five of my
theories pertaining to the trailer let's
get into it number one where is tina
goldstein
okay now we've had two trailers and one
teaser but absolutely no sign of
porpentina goldstein one of the main
protagonists of both fantastic beasts
and where to find them as well as
fantastic beasts the crimes of
grindelwald in the previous two films we
were given a considerable amount of the
american half blood witch and auras
backstory like the fact that she
attended ilvermorny school of witchcraft
and wizardry and the fact that she was
sorted into thunderbird house she's even
the sister of queenie who's still in the
film so it seems highly unusual that she
would be absent from yet another trailer
so what's the deal well my answer is
this tina goldstein fans should rest
easy as porpentina is far too
intertwined into the story to be removed
altogether i can say this with
confidence for a few reasons first of
all queenie goldstein tina's sister is
still a massive part of the plot and
shows up in the trailer on several
occasions
removing her sister for no apparent
reason would be a huge continuity error
and it just wouldn't make sense i don't
think they'd make a critical error like
that
second of all fantastic beasts fans who
are privy to harry potter lore should
already know that tina eventually
becomes the wife of newt scamander who
just so happens to be the main character
of the films we also know that they go
on to have children removing her would
be far too disruptive to the film and
harry potter cannon it would also
invalidate the tension that has been
building between newt and tina in the
films released thus far lastly catherine
waterston who plays tina has been
credited for the role
so where is she
my theory is that tina is hidden in
plain sight that is we've seen her in
every trailer so far we just didn't
realize it tinam is newt's assistant
bunty
now i'm not saying that bunty isn't an
actual person independent from tina she
totally is but what i'm suggesting is
that tina has used apologies potion to
assume the physical form of bunty now
you might be asking why
i think there are a few reasons for this
but the primary motivation for assuming
the form of bunty is that she's less of
a target bunty is a very unassuming
character already close to newt so
hanging around him wouldn't really arise
any suspicion
this effectively allows tina to act in a
more covert fashion and it might also
allow her to avoid unnecessary
interactions with her sister queenie who
has now switched sides in the trailer we
also see bunty acting a bit out of
character looking at newt quite firmly
and saying no one can know everything
not even you there's also the
possibility that since we're further
along in the future tina is pregnant
with newt's child staying out of the way
to avoid danger although i feel like
this one is a bit premature what do you
think number two the blood pact it's
well known that dumbledore and
grindelwald entered into a blood pact
when they were young
a blood pact is a type of magically
binding agreement between two parties
who shared their blood it could be made
by the parties cutting their hands with
their wands and interlacing them and
making the desired oath upon doing this
two glowing drops of blood would raise
from their palms and mingle into one
thereafter a file would take shape
around it enclosing the drop signifying
that the deal was struck and serving as
a physical manifestation of it once made
the file was supposedly impossible to
destroy
in the case of dumbledore and
grindelwald they made an oath never to
fight each other and grindelwald held
the file in his possession as a
safeguard so that dumbledore wouldn't be
able to try and destroy it as long as
the blood pact remained neither man
could attack the other however in the
secret of dumbledore trailer we see the
file containing their blood in
dumbledore's possession it was given to
dumbledore by newt in the previous film
dumbledore is staring at it presumably
figuring out a way to destroy it and
later in that same trailer we see the
two men dumbledore and grindelwald
fighting if they're actually fighting
and this isn't some kind of dream
sequence or out of body experience then
it means that the pact has been broken
we know that dumbledore eventually
defeats grindelwald in an epic jewel but
i hadn't expected them to duel so early
on in the films grindelwald's defeated
in 1945 and this film is supposed to
take place in 1939. so what's the deal
is this occurring in another dimension
does it jump ahead to 1945 is this the
last film or do we still have two more
number three for the greater good
at one point in the trailer we see
dumbledore and grindelwald sitting
across from one another having a rather
intense conversation grindelwald says to
albus rather ominously with or without
you i'll burn down their world
this is a scary line and once again
paints grindelwald with the brush of the
bad guy and bad guy he certainly is
however a line from that same
conversation later on made me think a
little bit staring dumbledore right in
the eyes grindelwald says to him it was
you who said we would reshape the world
to me this is big because it suggested
perhaps grindelwald's plan of
restructuring the world for the greater
good establishing a new world hierarchy
and enslaving muggles was actually the
master plan of albus dumbledore he just
brought grindelwald along for the ride
up to this point we were led to believe
that the two boys co-created everything
even the slogan but what this could
suggest is that dumbledore was the
original diabolical mastermind only
leaving his plans behind and gaining
perspective after the death of his
sister
4. yusuf karma yusuf karma born in 1884
was a french pureblood wizard of
senegalese ancestry his character is
little all over the place in the films
and he's not exactly a good guy but he
doesn't appear to be evil either he's
grey at least from what we can tell so
far when we're first introduced to yusuf
he's hell-bent on killing credence and
that's because he believed credence to
be corvus lestrange the son of corvus
lestrange iv a man who would use the
imperious curse to marry yusuf's mother
he was also acting under an unbreakable
vow imposed by his father that had him
seek revenge by killing the person who
lestrange loved most in the world after
learning that his foul was void due to
corvus already being dead yusuf started
to display a more moral and selfless
side and was not at all tempted by
grindelwald's persuasive speech at the
lestrange mausoleum
at this point gama risks his life to
save nagini from the black fire and then
helps nicola flamel as well as his
former enemies by conjuring purifying
orange flames but in the new trailer i'm
not entirely sure where yusuf's
allegiance lies in some scenes he's with
the good guys he's even on the train
with them but in others he can be seen
standing behind and interacting with
grindelwald as if he is an acolyte of
grindelwald's so what's the deal
provided that there's a scene in the
trailer where grindelwald is using his
wand to extract something from yusuf i'm
willing to bet that he has manipulated
yusuf in some way in order to bring him
over to his side perhaps he offered to
take away yusuf's painful memories from
childhood or maybe he took away the
memories of him allying up with newt and
gang or maybe just maybe use the
imperius curse to bring yusuf under his
control
number 5. the mirror in the trailer we
see who has been revealed to be young at
before dumbledore staring into a mirror
as words begin to form
this scene has been in both trailers so
far
the only problem with this part of the
trailer is that the sentence is
incomplete we're only given a little bit
of it
so what does it say and where do these
words come from this mirror if you
didn't know is of course a two-way
mirror one in a pair of mirrors that are
magically connected
this type of magical artifact allows
people to communicate with each other
while in different locations immediately
after seeing amber forth it cuts to
albus so clearly the two are using
mirrors to communicate what message did
albus send to his brother
all i can make out is do you know the
top with the standalone sections of w h
i s and i k e
at the bottom it also looks like there's
a question mark at the end of the
sentence i spoke with one who helps run
harry potter theory espanol today and he
seemed to think that it might say
do you know what it's like this would
effectively be dropping an emotional
bomb onto his brother which could make
sense given that aberforth blames him
for so much
however it's also possible that this
text isn't significant at all
later in life albus says the following
of his brother
of course i'm not entirely sure he can
read it sounds like a joke but maybe
there's some truth to it who knows what
do you guys think it says i'd love to
hear what you think and that's it for
this video if you enjoyed the content
please like the video and subscribe to
support the channel
until next time remember
it does not do to dwell on dreams and
forget to live
you